I have about $30,000 in student debt
that's what amount of my student debt is
approximately $90,000 my student loan
debt is one hundred and sixty eight
thousand dollars
the deck collective is in New Orleans
today because we want to ask why free
higher education isn't on the table and
discussion at the national conference
I wanted to be a face to show the impact
that the student loan crisis that has on
life
it's on my credit file it's not
something that will allow me the
flexibility to go do things that
motional other Americans can do get a
housecat car apply for any loan from a
bank it's been a big distraction just a
very heavy burden on the shoulders of my
life it's it's very crushing
you